مرحبًا بكم في شنغهاي ديزني لاند حيث
نحصل على نظرة خاطفة لما
ستبدو عليه العمليات الجديدة
لهذه الحديقة وإعادة فتحها بعد ثلاثة أشهر ونصف
من إغلاقها
بسبب تفشي فيروس كورونا الجديد
هنا في الصين الآن بشكل طبيعي
عندما ''  عند
إعادة فتحهم ، سيتعين عليهم ارتداء قناع
يمكننا خلعه لأن
الحشد لم يكن موجودًا بعد ولكن كما ترون
الاستعدادات جارية ، فقد استخدموا
هذه المرة لإعادة التفكير  كيف سيحصلون
على أشخاص يأتون بأمان
للحفاظ على تلك المسافة الاجتماعية
وتجنب أي نوع من الاتصال ليس فقط
مع بعضهم البعض ولكن أيضًا مع أعضاء فريق التمثيل ،
لذلك ستبدو الأشياء
بشكل مختلف قليلاً
وسأخذك خارج الحديقة إلى  نوضح
لك كيف دخلنا مع
عمليات نائب الرئيس الأول أندرو بول ستيك ،
نطلب من ضيوفنا القيام ببعض الأشياء بشكل
مختلف عن ذي قبل ، وهو أننا
نطلب من كل ضيف لدينا
فحص درجة الحرارة عند وصولهم
هنا في المنتجع ، نطلب منهم أيضًا
إظهار رمز الاستجابة السريعة الخاص بهم وهو
رمز صحي خاص بشنغهاي ، وضعنا القليل
من العلامات والعلامات الرئيسية المنظمة
في مكانها بحيث تكون واضحة جدًا ولا
تقف هنا ، ثم تقف
في الفراغ  مسافة بينهما كما هو الحال دائمًا ،
نطلب بطاقة هوية حكومية لاسترداد التذاكر الخاصة بك
عند المدخل ، لكننا سنحصل أيضًا
على معلومات الهوية الحكومية
لكل ضيف يأتي
إلى المتنزه وليس واحدًا فقط لكل طرف
كجزء من إجراءات التتبع التي
لدينا  في مكانه الآن للإرشادات الحكومية ،
أعطنا فكرة ، أعني
أننا نسير عبر ما سيلاحظه الناس
أنه مختلف ، أعني شيئًا واحدًا
رأيته بالنسبة لي هو
الصرف الصحي المستمر ، نعم ، لذلك لدينا
فريق متخصص جدًا من عمال النظافة الحراسة
حتى أننا قمنا بزيادة أعداد
الأشخاص في جميع أنحاء المنتزه الذين يقومون
بمسح جميع الأسطح باستمرار
أثناء سيرك على طول الخط هنا
ستلاحظ الأماكن التي يمكنك التوقف
فيها والأماكن التي تحتاج إليها  احتفظ بمسافة
، ثم تصل في النهاية إلى نقطة
الجذب ويطلب من الضيف أن
يفهمها من أجل صحتك
وسلامتك ، فالطاولة غير متوفرة ،
لذا فنحن نطلب من الضيوف
عدم الجلوس هنا ، ومرة أخرى يخ
ق نوعًا من هذا الفصل بي
جميع الحفلات المختلفة توفر مساحة
حتى بالنسبة للعروض ، فهذه
إحدى المراحل ، انظر هنا في الحشد ، اختر
صندوقًا حيث ستقف أنت ووحدتك العائلية
مع الحفاظ على تلك المسافة ،
وسنكون قادرين على تحقيق هذا التوازن الصحيح
بين السلامة و  جانب الصحة
والثقة ، ثم السحر
الذي يمكننا تقديمه كل يوم
تشعر فيه بطرق عديدة أنه ليس فقط
أجزاء أخرى من الشركة تبحث هنا
وأجزاء أخرى نأمل أن تعيد
فتح أبوابها ولكن ربما
ترى شركات أخرى كيف  يفعلون ذلك ،
ربما يساعدنا ذلك في إعادة فتح موقع
Everywhere بشكل مختلف قليلاً على
الرغم من وجود لوائح مختلفة ،
فهناك بيئات
مختلفة يكون الأشخاص فيها مراحل مختلفة من  e وباء
ولكني أعتقد أن ما لدينا يمكن أن يكون نموذجًا ، آمل أن يكون
مصدر إلهام لهم
وسوف يقومون بتكييفه مع الظروف المحلية الخاصة بهم
مع المشغلين الآخرين في
جميع أنحاء العالم الذين
نتواصل معهم ونشاركها في هذا النوع من
البيئة حيث  نريد التركيز على
السلامة والصحة وهذا مجال
نتشاركه جميعًا معًا